We say, welcome to Ear Biscuits.
Is that how we say, 'cause
if we say, some reason that--
Welcome to Ear Biscuits.
Yeah, that's like, it's like
is welcome the first word?
'Cause that seems really
odd to me right now.
Yo, oh, it's easy.
Sounds like I must have.
You're really fresh, man?
What do you think it should be now
that you're back from your solo trips?
Change it.
Greetings.
Greetings, okay do it.
Greeting that's it.
Greetings and welcome to Ear Biscuits.
The podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting.
I'm gonna talk about the
trip that I am fresh off of.
I got home last night
from six days of van life,
boondocking in the middle
of nowhere, camping.
Just me and my wife, some
national parks, a lot of Utah,
probably Mormons, I didn't know.
Yeah.
You know?
Just statistically.
I didn't ask
Just statistically speaking,
probably ran into a few Mormons.
I didn't run over anybody,
I didn't run into anybody.
Like there were no--
That's good.
There were no accidents, but
I will say on the last night
something happened to
us that I just have to,
I wanna tell you the whole story.
It just, I was so scared, okay.
I'll just say we, Christy
and I both got really scared.
Okay.
And it was just a strange story.
And I just wanna tell the whole thing,
and that's why I texted you
this morning, I was like,
"Hey, I think for coming
here to record first thing,
"fresh off our trips,
"I think I've got with everything
I wanna share with you.
"I've got a whole episode."
If it's okay for you to
then have another episode,
I don't care who goes first.
Right and so today we're
gonna hear about your trip.
Next time we'll hear about my trip.
I will give you just a short preview.
Which incidentally
includes me being scared.
Dude, I was thinking about you a lot.
I was like, I wonder,
okay, we'll get into it.
So, but it also,
so it also includes an update on
the conversation/argument/debate.
Am I a competitive person.
That we turned into an entire episode.
I had some time to think about that.
And I have sort of,
I have some perspective on that.
I definitely do not want that.
Just trust me.
It will not be a majority
or even a significant part of the episode.
It's just an update.
Are you saying this to
me so I'm not scared?
No, I'm saying it to--
To them.
I'm saying it to all the people who,
some people enjoyed that conversation
and some people didn't.
You know, I only saw some people's like,
this is the first one I've never, I did,
I just had to quit listening to.
Yeah, I saw that.
And I totally get that
because it felt like it was,
some people don't wanna hear
like, turn into a debate.
So I have just an update
on some perspective,
that kinda came to me in the desert
and also just a summary of my trip
and some other things that happened.
But let's hear about yours.
Even right at the beginning of this,
when you said greetings and
you had a different voice.
Is that the new Rhett voice?
I was playing into.
Okay.
Are we gonna include--
Sure.
The part that we--
I think we did.
Yeah, they heard it.
Yeah, I basically forgot how
the Ear Biscuits started.
I mean, like, I literally
forgot how it started.
I do have this feeling, first of all,
I'm not totally awake.
I should have, I had a coffee.
I should have a second coffee.
I do feel like I've,
I need a day.
Like the experience that I
had and that Christy I had
that I share is gonna be very raw
because I haven't fully
assimilated back into life.
I think that's what, are gonna
feeling that a little bit?
And I got home--
Get home last night.
I got home last night later,
even later than you did,
like I came home basically
as the sun was going down.
Six days of camping, turns
out that's a long time.
And I was not alone.
I can't, I mean, I really
wanna hear your experience
'cause I've imagined a lot of.
And we're gonna record mine tomorrow.
So it just one day apart.
So it'll still be fresh.
It'll still be fresh for me.
Okay, okay.
Well, just to give an overview of my trip,
we ended up deciding, let's
say we drove past Vegas.
And when we stopped in Vegas
and we got something to eat,
I mean, we just ate in the car.
That's the great thing about
this sprinter van is that--
What did you eat?
What did you serve?
While we were gonna go through
the Raising Cane's drive thru--
Oh crap, I stopped in Raising
Cane's in Vegas yesterday.
So did I.
No, you didn't.
Yes.
Hold on,
you ate at Raising Cane's
in Vegas yesterday?
No two days ago, I'm sorry.
I ate at Raising Cane's--
When we were coming back through.
I saw the sign I was like,
"Oh, Raising Cane's."
Chicken tenders.
I got to try this out, everybody,
Post Malone also went to it.
And so I got in, ate in my car.
While we were trying
to eat there on the way
and then the sprinter van
would not go through the drive thru.
So we had--
The Raising Cane's I went through,
went to, 'cause I hadn't
mind rooftop tent on,
I thought about this.
There was no overhang.
So we went to a different ones.
I went to the one on
the east side of Vegas.
I can't say which one I went to.
'Cause as soon as I wanna drive--
Too much traffic there--
'Cause I was coming from
the east coming back home.
Okay, but there's more than two.
Yeah, and as I saw the sign, I was like,
"Well, I'm going there."
It's pretty good, right?
I mean, it's like, I would
say it's like Zack Spees,
but a little better.
My opinion was the chicken is good.
Chicken is great.
The fries are horrible.
I thought the fries were horrible.
I'm comparing them to Bojangles
and Bojangles fries are way better.
Dipping sauce was good.
And then we'd already had that.
That's the only thing I've had slaw bad.
Slaw was bad, yeah.
Tea good, I got tea.
I didn't get the tea maybe I
should've have got the tea.
They didn't have a biscuit though.
Oh, Texas toast.
Oh, the Texas toast was good.
It was good, yeah.
That and the chicken tender--
I highly recommend it.
So we start there, but
we're eating in the van.
We're peeing and pooping in the van.
We're washing our hands in the van.
There's a shower, we could
even shower in the van,
but there's also a hose
off of the back of the van
where we ended up showering.
And because it was--
'Cause the shower on
the inside is so small?
So small and there's a toilet in it.
Oh yeah totally the toilet.
No toilet toilet.
Are you gonna talk about--
But it was hot water.
Are gonna talk about the pooping?
Are you gonna get into that?
Sure, yeah.
Because I'm gonna get
into that on my trip.
As time allows for me,
we have to throw back--
Perspective, okay.
To my experience when, once I hear yours.
'Cause I would not say that's a highlight
or something that I plan
on talking about at length,
but I'm always game to talk
poop if you wanna go far.
For me it will not be an
insignificant part of my story.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'll just add some about
two cents at that point.
But until then, I'm just
gonna say, you know,
we stayed in the van.
We got the five guys take
out, we took it to the car.
On the way back through is
where we went to Raising Cane's
and we figured out we could call them
and they would bring it out to us.
And that's when ate that.
Cub side, I saw that sign.
And when we,
we kept going from Vegas,
from there we decided,
I saw one of the Sklar brothers tweeted
that they were at Zion and I was like,
"Am a direct message Sklar bros." You know
I haven't talked to him in
a while, but we're like,
they know who I am.
And I said, I'm thinking
about going to Zion,
but I'm concerned about the crowds,
the COVID regulations and everything,
and you can't get on the shuttle.
I have no shuttle reservation.
And he said,
"Well, you should definitely
go do a private shuttle.
"You can pay,
"there's one, there's
shuttle companies that go in,
"you just get one of those
"and then you get on a private shuttle.
"They take you right."
'Cause Zion and we ended
up doing that and he said,
"We did the narrows hike, you
should definitely do that."
I saw the pictures, he
had like a walking stick
and these special boots.
And he was like wet.
I was like, "Okay, we're gonna do this."
Based on just direct messages and tweet.
'Cause I was just gonna go
to Bryce Canyon and skip it
because less people go there
and it's less regulated.
Anybody can go in.
But I began to understand
when I got there to Zion,
it's relatively small.
I mean, when you compare
it to like a Yosemite.
It's small on the map.
Yeah, it's this one canyon that,
I mean the Virgin River
just cuts through this thing
and it almost doubles back on itself.
And it makes these like
amphitheater areas.
And to get up into that canyon,
you have to be on a shuttle.
So they just don't let
cars go through there
'cause they would jam up the whole thing.
And so that's why the shuttle
thing is so important.
So we get up and we made
a reservation of 9:30
be picked up, we go out there and--
How far, how much ahead of
time did you have to call
to make this reservation?
It was noon, I was, it
was noon the day before.
And they had a few spots
open in on that shuttle.
And so we went the next morning,
we go out there and the
shuttle takes you all the way
through to the back end of
the park where it's like,
it is a, cul-de-sac basically
like a river made sheer wall,
like thousands of foot
tall, like red rock,
mountain climber heaven type thing.
I don't even wanna try to explain it.
You can look at the
pictures and it's like,
they always say, until you go,
you really can't appreciate it--
Is it better than Yosemite?
It's so much smaller
and so much different.
It's like going to an attraction.
There's only, you can really do it.
I mean, you can spend multiple
days there and enjoy it.
But I felt like we just did that one day
and we did the one hike and I was like,
"You know what,
"we're gonna move on
to Bryce the next day.
"We'll call it a travel day."
Which is a different national park.
Yeah, so just to tell you
about the narrows hike,
you're hiking in the river,
which is like it's, I mean,
it is curved this deep chasm.
Yeah, this is the one
you see on Instagram.
Yeah and it's just absolutely amazing.
Like, you know, I can show
you some of the pictures,
but there's no, after you
hike in a little ways,
everyone's just getting in the river
and there's no trail anymore.
And you're just hiking in the river.
And it's usually like shin deep.
Sometimes it went to mid thigh,
deep on me and it was cold.
And I was like, I was taught,
I was trying to get
Christy like ready for it.
I was like, "You know what?
"We're gonna," she's like,
"We can turn back at any time."
And this is before we get
in the water and I'm like,
"Come on, we gotta do this."
What kind of shoes did you have on?
I just had on our quick,
dry, low top shoes.
We didn't wear our boots
but these people have like--
The ones that we took to like Fiji.
No, not like water socks,
just like hiking shoes.
But low top.
We didn't wanna wear a high top
because they would get real soggy.
At least that's what we thought.
I mean, people are renting like
these waterproof hiking boots
with like ankle support.
You really do need ankle support
and they give you a stick
and you're supposed to
use that to stay up.
But like, I've walked
in the river so much.
It was easy to walk over all these rocks.
It was like, when we
crossed the Cape Fear River,
except the water was
clear for the most part--
And cold.
And really cold but you
could turn your ankle
and you could fall down easily.
But I think we gained confidence
when we saw like retirees
trudging through this thing.
And we were wearing a mask
there's a lot of people
going up to this thing
but it was a hike unlike anything else.
And we go up there for a
number of miles and it's just,
it gets to a point where
it gets really narrow.
I mean, it could have been
like 15 feet apart, like sheer,
a thousand foot in the air, it
seemed like, and it was like,
and you're just walking
through the up this
what I would call a stream.
It's not really a river by that point.
It was amazing.
Sounds like there could be a
problem if it was to flood.
Yes, but they take all that into account
in terms of, I guess they had confidence
that there wasn't going
to be a flash flood
or they would have shut it down.
And there was so many,
I mean, even with COVID,
there was a lot of people hiking there.
But it was totally worth it.
The next day, I'm gonna go
through the park stuff now,
because what I really wanna talk about
is the camping experience.
And then the story that happened.
Okay, so, I mean, that
was a super cool hike.
I definitely recommend that for everybody.
Like I was thinking the
kids would've loved it
as once they got over
the cold of the water,
your feet getting numb and then--
And this has gotta be as
warm as the water gets,
you would think.
I would think so.
It wasn't faced by being,
it was like in the mid 80s,
actually it was in the low 80s.
It was like an,
it was like perfect weather to be there.
Right.
And then, so we camped that night,
the next day we took it,
we took like an easy day of just camping,
like getting going late.
But then we drove to Bryce Canyon which,
it was like, you wind
your way up out of Zion.
And you go through, when these,
when the tunnel was built
through the mountain,
it's like the longest tunnel in the world
at the time it was built in like 1920.
And it was crazy,
you're like going through
the mountain on this--
How long are you talking about?
Like, I'm gonna know, I don't know--
If it was the longest one in
the world, it's gotta be--
Like 10 minutes to get through it.
I mean, at least a mile.
Oh yeah and we can look it up.
I was driving, I couldn't Google.
I was like, "It's dark in here."
But 10 Minutes to go through.
Yeah.
So several miles.
Yeah, I mean, we were going pretty slow.
We were probably going,
oh, we're going 30 miles an hour, 25.
Anyway you wind up out of there.
And then you drive for
like a little over an hour,
an hour and a half, and
you get to Bryce, which is,
it's kinda like, if you've
ever been to the Grand Canyon,
you go in and it kinda feels the same.
'Cause you're in the woods
and you go to the edge of this canyon.
You walk to the rim of it.
And then it's all of these
hoodoos is what they're called.
Like, you know if you make a sand castle,
the type of sand castle people
can make on the beach where
they like drip sand in it,
like the sand just plop, plop,
plops on top of each other.
It's like that except done
by erosion, not by addition.
And there is this, like these
pinnacles of sandstone stuff
just everywhere.
And it's like a magical fairyland
that you're walking down through them.
So we did a hike down through there
and it's cool that it's so
close and it also was small.
So it felt like I can see
all of this in one day.
I can hang out for a couple of days
and really appreciate it.
But I can also move on knowing
that I got an idea of what
this national parks like, and
I've done one of the more,
one of the most famous trails.
So we did that the next
day camped that night.
And then we drove back down
just to get closer to home.
We drove down to the other
side of Vegas, like, well,
on this side of Vegas,
there's a place called
Red Rocks National Preservation Area.
And it's like, so we looked at all that,
there's like a cool scenic drive
right outside of, like
the mountains you see--
On 15 on the main highway?
To the west of Vegas,
like that mountain range.
There's like this Red Rock mountain range.
But you have to get off of the--
Interstate?
We, yeah.
No, but is it like, 'cause
I thought just yesterday
I drove there and I was kind of,
I was like, I'm trying to get
home by a reasonable time.
So I didn't stop at anything.
I didn't see any signs for that.
That's all like the
Mojave National Reserve.
Yeah it's--
Before that.
Yeah, it's right outside of Vegas.
Like literally, if you
go west out of Vegas,
there's like these condos and
like these desert communities
they build up that are like really nice.
And then it turns into nothing.
And if you go south around the Red Rock,
that's where we camped the last night.
And then instead of coming
back down into Vegas,
we went around that and skirted
the edge of Death Valley.
It actually said it was faster
from where we had camped
the last night where the story happened.
Are you gonna talk about camping?
Ask you how hot it was.
I picked that place because
it wasn't the hottest night,
but everywhere I picked it was just trying
to like escape the heat and
anything that might be burning.
That's why I didn't camp
near Vegas the last night
'cause I was like the
weather and I was like,
"Ah, that's gonna be like
105 during the day and--
That was the high, like
down at like Vegas level.
But then once you got into
that, like hilly rocky area,
that where we camped, I picked it because
it was probably like a high of
85 there actually, maybe 90,
but then, so it wasn't
uncomfortable at night.
So we went there and then
we skirted the edge of Death Valley.
We saw hot springs 'cause I saw a sign,
took like a two minute detour,
dumped our crap and our water.
Like literally you gotta, I gotta, well,
we'll talking about the crap later.
Well, hot springs?
Tecopa, it's just some little town,
but it was just some guy at a booth.
And then behind his booth where it was,
there's like a men's shack and
a women's shack and showers.
And then he let me look at it
and it was just like a pool,
like a actually it
wasn't rustic in any way.
And I didn't have time to
get in I was just curious.
I need to dump my crap
and get outta there.
And then we came home.
You mean he had felt
they had pumped the water
into like a tub.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The water flowed in and
there was a hot water pool.
Like it looked like a
big rectangular pool.
Like 15 people could get
in, but nobody was in it.
And then there was a cold
pool on the other side
in another room and you had
to be nude and it wasn't coed.
You only do nude if
it's coed is that right?
That's right.
Right, I swear like I'm out, I'm out.
You see, you know what?
I wouldn't do either one on
its own, it's gotta be both.
But the main experience
that I'm taking way--
I will talk about that by the way.
Okay, yeah, I know you
were aiming for hot springs
so I wanna hear about that.
My main takeaway was not
the beauty of these parks,
but it was the experience camping.
So that's what I wanna spend
the most time talking about.
And then telling you the story
about how I got freaked out
night before last, our
last night there camping.
So I'll get into all that.
But first let's promote some stuff.
You know what?
We made a lot of merch
when we wrote our book,
"The Lost Course of Bleak Creek."
And we don't regret it, you
sounded like you regretted it.
We made a lot of merch, man.
No, I'm just saying and it's
going to be gone forever.
And so it's in the last chance section
of the mythical.com store.
So if you want anything
like this sweatshirt
that Link has on--
May be gone right now--
Or, yeah I know, I mean, it's
in the last chance section,
we're recording this
few weeks ahead of time.
It could be gone, but go over there.
That whole last chance section
doesn't just have the Bleak Creek merch,
it's got anything that we're discontinuing
and not bringing back.
For instance, I'm drinking out of this
good luck with that mug, you know,
this doesn't exist anymore.
You cannot, you can't buy
this anymore, can you?
I don't think so, no.
You can't buy this anymore
because we make a limited run
of everything that we do, so--
Gotta to move on, gotta to keep going.
So good luck with that--
What lies ahead we have no way of knowing.
But under our feet, baby,
the grass is growing,
time to move on, time to keep going.
Is that a--
It's Tom Petty song.
Okay, got it.
Mythical.com, get your stuff
last chance before it's over.
Oh man, I gotta shave immediately
after this, like I want--
You're itching.
Yeah, this is the worst phase.
And I took my razor camping.
I was like, who's gonna
shave when camping.
What kind of chump shaves when camping?
People who commit to longterm camping--
And also shaving, shave.
They do shave.
I think I would do that.
Yeah, I met some people,
I met several clean shaven people.
Oh yeah, who were permanently
as Christy calls them, road travelers.
Yeah, I mean like--
She could not remember
the word for hitchhiker.
And we encounter this guy on a back road
who he was just walking
down and I pulled over--
He was clean shaven?
I pulled over, he had a huge beard
and I was like, do you need any help?
And he had the most paranoid,
guilty look on his face.
Like he just killed
someone and he was like--
I don't need any help kill
anybody, I do it alone.
I was like, okay and I was like,
"I don't know why I
stopped and talked to you."
Did he, if he doesn't,
if he's not like he funny--
He was in the middle of
nowhere and he was walking.
And using my instinct
is just to keep going,
like let him eat the dust but
I was being very altruistic.
And then I got a little scared.
That is a good point though,
because I met a couple,
just a young couple that was moving.
They were in the process of trying to move
from New Jersey to California in a van.
And they were like, these fires started.
And so where we were gonna go
is basically on fire right now.
So we're kind of just hanging
out, this was in Nevada.
And they had been on the
road for like three weeks
and he was completely clean shaven
and I haven't thought about that at all.
And he was not the kind of
man who can't grow a beard.
I could see the potential for a beard.
I think he was--
He was just a shaver.
He had his destination in mind
and I think it's psychological.
It's like, you know what, for that guy,
I'm putting a lot on him.
But I think, his tie
to the civilized world
is him continuing to shave.
And once he stopped shaving,
he was giving up on his
hope of ever reconnecting
with society on the west coast
where he was gonna make a life for himself
and I presume his partner.
Yeah and the hashtag van life.
And they were like take,
they were in a converted Astro,
a four wheel drive Astro.
No judgement.
And that had a popup thing on it.
And I could tell by
the way that the woman,
his companion was taking
pictures of like this hot spring
that we were at and everything
and waiting for the sunset.
And she went to the hot spring
and she moved things around.
I was like, this is a
total hashtag van life.
And like, they're getting
these really good pictures.
I can only imagine what this
Instagram is gonna look like.
Well, our van was, everything was,
it had all the amenities,
but the materials that they
used to make everything
were very rugged.
It felt like you could just take a hose
and hose everything off..
Because it's a rental and I mean,
they touted how much they
rigorously clean the thing.
In between people using it.
If you were to do your own deal,
you would want like
mahogany, what do you--
Yeah, the ones, it wasn't picturesque
because you start to think
about hashtag van life
is these people who
put stuff on Instagram.
And I was sitting in the
back of the van on our,
the day after Zion, when we were like,
we're just gonna take this day.
We're not gonna rush off
the, we're gonna wake up,
we're gonna eat breakfast,
we're gonna hang out here.
Hell, We may even take
a nap before lunchtime--
A late morning nap.
Yeah, which we did.
Yeah, never been done before.
And then I was like, you know what?--
That seems almost impossible.
Before--
Yeah, I know, right?
The whole hanging around in the morning,
which for me ended up being the highlight.
I'll talk about that,
but never did it strike me that
I should get back in
the tent and take a nap.
Like not even--
Well these are, it's different.
The back doors of the van are open.
This is a hashtag van life moment.
You lay down in the bed
and then you stand up towards
the cab at the driver's seat.
And someone takes a photo
through the back of the van
at the scenery someone's--
Did you take a bunch of photos
that you're gonna post hashtag van life?
Well, I said,
"Christy, come in here
and take a picture of me."
I was laying on the bed thinking
about maybe taking a nap.
She was outside reading a book.
And I was like, "Come in
here, take a picture."
And so she takes my phone
and she comes right up to me.
I was like, "No, no, no.
"Haven't you seen go back to the cab,
"you wanna shoot past me."
And then we try to do that.
And then I looked at the
pictures and I was like,
you know what I'm not gonna
blame Christy for this.
It's the decor, it's the light,
so many things have to line up
for it to be hashtaggable van life.
And let me tell you, it was not worth it
because that right there--
I think it ruins the enjoyment.
It proved to me how much of a,
if you get really good at it
you can probably do it quickly,
but it takes a lot of practice
to look like you're cool out there.
When this woman--
Van life in it.
This woman went to the hot spring,
she just moved a bunch of
stuff around the hot spring.
And then started taking pictures.
No, I was, I'll explain why,
but I was very close to the hot spring.
The thing that I didn't fully anticipate,
I guess I could have known this,
but it's one thing to say
it, it's another thing,
it's kinda like going to a park.
You can say how beautiful it
is, but until you're there,
you really can't experience it.
I think in a similar way, I could've known
that this camping excursion
would have been unlike any other,
but I really didn't think it
through until it was happening.
First of all, me and Christy,
the best of my recollection,
we've never gone camping
just the two of us.
Yeah me and Jesie have never done it.
Every time that I would go camping.
I mean, in college we would go
and it was also mission oriented.
We're gonna go to this place
so that we can experience
these things so that
we can do these things.
And whenever we would
start going off-roading,
like when we first moved
out here and we're like,
we did the Death Valley
trips and stuff like that,
camping was kind of just
the means to bed down
in between doing more
off-roading, you know?
The most prevalent experience at camping
is bringing the kids.
And there's so much logistics associated
with once you have one, two or three kids.
Good gosh.
Right, definitely one too many.
And you know, it's just trying
to keep everybody straight
and keep everything together.
And somebody is all,
everybody's opinions
and everybody's on edge.
I didn't realize how,
I came with a mentality of, this is not,
everything we talked about
in the last Ear Biscuit
it's not about,
it's just about taking
every day as it comes.
And as my desired outcome is
quality time with Christy.
And then hopefully that this
is overall a great experience
that we can then do again.
So within that context,
I started to realize,
I started to have thoughts
like the first night
when we were camping and
setting up the campus so easy,
there was no tent to set up.
There was no fire to
start, which is illegal.
I just had that propane tank.
And you just fire that
up, cook some stuff,
you immediately turn it off and on.
And like, it doesn't spread
flames at all, it's legal.
But it makes it so simple.
I found myself having this--
Abundance of time.
Headspace to think and I
actually had the thought
for the first time, I'm
starting to connect with nature.
Like you hear people talking about
how they go out into nature and like,
some people say,
"Well, I feel closest to
God when I'm in nature."
Or I just like to connect with the earth.
And I was like, you know,
hunters do that in their own way.
They connect with it so hard--
So hard, so this--
They kill it.
But it's this like primal
thing, like farmers do it,
they get their hands dirty.
They like have a relationship
with the earth that they learn
to speak its language and to
give to it and benefit from it.
And I actually started
to having these thoughts,
just like a level of
appreciation for connection,
with nature that,
on all of the campuses I've been through,
there just wasn't a lot of space for that.
And you know, we're like setting
up our camp, we're eating,
we're watching the sun go down--
And it also helps in,
I'm assuming this was your experience.
'Cause definitely my experience.
It also helps for me when
you're not in an established campground.
To me that like--
Dispersed camping for the win.
That made all the difference in the world
in being able to--
Waiting for you to say for the win--
To feel like there's an
opportunity to connect
because when you're in this,
like, okay, well there's this,
especially when it's like a pay--
If you're at a campground.
Campground and there's
a building over there
that a person built that
you can take a crap in.
That to me, that just takes away from it.
Even if the scenery is
beautiful and then also,
oh and there's another person
right there next to you
and you can hear their conversation.
You can like hear,
even if you can't make
out what they're saying,
you can kinda just hear
You can't stand that.
And it's like,
okay, that's part of camping
is what we've thought.
And we have camp like totally isolated,
but we've done it with other people.
Like when we went to Death
Valley, there was nobody around,
in many of those nights
except for the group.
But it was like five trucks full of guys.
So you still have that.
There's no isolation, but yeah
definitely that first night
we found this amazing campsite
just outside of Zion on
national forest land
using the ioverlander app.
That was the app that worked best for me.
I ended up using that yeah.
We didn't have cell service,
but the spot was so good.
We were like, all right,
we're going to Zion tomorrow.
We're gonna come back to the
same spot and enjoy it again
because it's such a good spot.
Like we could see the sunset,
there was like a ravine right
there, there were red rocks.
It was amazing.
I took a Garmin satellite phone.
Not a sponsor.
I think it was the enrich
or something like that.
And so even when I
didn't have cell service,
I could text Jessie and it texts her
and she gets a text on her phone--
And a location.
And a link to my location on the map.
Oh, that's cool, I'll get one of those.
And it's like a monthly service
that you can turn on and off.
And I think it was like
30 bucks for the month.
And then you just turn it off
and it's stagnant while
you're not using it.
That's nice peace of mind because yeah--
I mean, I was by myself.
Yeah, so--
I definitely had to do that.
Yeah, so that isolation, it really creates
so much more space than
I even anticipated.
And it was just, it was relaxing
and so it gets dark, you're hanging out
and I turn off the,
actually I didn't turn
off the propane fire yet.
We were like sitting around the fire.
We were looking up at
where we were just like,
"Man, look at the stars."
Oh yeah.
It was it's the time of year,
it took me a while to figure out why,
I mean, it was totally clear.
The most stars I had ever seen except for
that night that we landed
in Fiji and it was dark.
And we got on a boat
that had no lights on it.
And they took us out to that Island
that we stayed out for a week.
And we looked up at the
sky on this boat which,
Christy and I were talking
about that and we were like,
"I can't believe we did that."
Like in the middle of the night,
it felt like in the pitch dark,
we get on this boat and
then we're just going out
and there's no lights on
the boat it seemed like
because we would look up and
we saw so many stars that,
and it took me back there because
that was the only time
I'd seen as many stars
as we saw that night.
And I turn off the fire
and I turn off all the lights on the van
and we just craned our necks and just,
we watched the stars
like we were watching a movie
and that had never happened.
And you can see like the bright light
sort of like clusters
stars beyond the stars.
I was like, is that the Milky Way?
Well you're in the Milky Way.
And then, yeah, I convinced
Christy it was the Milky Way.
And then we came home and Lily's like,
"Dad, you're in the Milky Way."
She was like, those are
nebulous, is what she said.
Did she say nebulous?
No, she said supernovas,
that's what she said.
Like, all the--
Supernova is an event.
But this is just more stars, right?
You can see, it was a
whole band across the sky,
like one band of more stars, right?
Yeah, you know what--
Like the Milky Way.
By the time I record mine,
I'll tell you what it is.
I'll know definitively.
'Cause I saw,
'cause you don't see that
at all in Los Angeles.
You don't need to think about the stars.
It was mesmerizing.
And I didn't, you know, like I said,
we were just watching it like
a movie and we were just,
it was a highlight, it was amazing.
And then--
Did you see,
we'll talk about aliens,
but did you see, when it's that clear
and you have that big of an expanse.
If you look for long
enough, you start seeing.
Shooting stars.
Yes, we were both looking up
and we saw the same shooting star
and it was like, "Whoa, we just saw that."
So like seeing a shooting
star together and just talking
about how, okay, first of all,
a shooting star is not a
star it's not to star at all,
a shooting stars is a meteor.
No shooting stars is the Milky Way
.
It's like, just to see this,
to both see a shooting
star, to see this meteor--
It's almost like,
what's the movie where the--
It's serendipity to share that--
Is it Fievel American Tail.
Is that where when you're
both looking at the same.
It's just like that.
It's like a red 'cause now
we were next to each other.
Is it Fievel or Fiefel?
Fievel.
And then we watched the
stars, we had eaten,
it was time to start
bend down for the night.
And then I realized,
and I had this thought
in the back of my head,
but it's not the type of
thing that I wanted to say
as part of my intention.
And I wanted to hold on loosely
because you don't wanna
attach too many expectations
and you don't,
a lot of things have to line up
for certain things to happen.
I'm interested where
you're going with this.
But that night it was like, you know what?
You're not trying to have
a fourth kid are you?
Because you're not capable of that.
No, that's not what this is about.
That's exactly what this about.
I'm talking about getting
into the van and saying,
"You know what, I brought some mail,
"you brought some mail.
"I think we need to sort this mail."
Yeah, right.
We should sort this mail.
The back doors of this van are open.
There's a nice space here
where we can lay out all
the mail and sort it.
Hold on, this is the
first of the last night.
This is the first night.
I'm about to say
hopefully this didn't wait
until the last night
before this figured out this could happen.
This is this first night.
And I knew it could happened, but I just--
You know it can happen.
I just never know, a lot of
things have to line up to say,
you know what, it's a good
time to sort the mail.
And if you're making a lot
of adjustments to a place,
the last thing you wanna do
sometimes is sort the mail.
And you got to have an
internet connection.
So you can look at the wikiHow
and know how to do it again.
Now I remember how to the mail.
And we just felt like--
For those of you who didn't
listen to that episode,
sorting the mail is
having sexual intercourse.
That's for them to find out.
Yeah, so we embark on sorting the mail.
It turns out we both brought
mail that needed to be sorted.
That's important, both
of you have to be sorted.
Right, yeah.
It just can't be one person.
Right, right.
That's very selfish.
Yeah, it's like both peoples,
I mean, if you both bring
mail, you should both sort it.
It should both be sorted.
Did you sort hers first?
Sort each other's mail.
'Cause you should really saw hers first,
don't be one of those guys.
Well I mean, it's like you,
if you wanna categorize your mail,
then you like put it into stacks
and then you might sort some, okay.
Some of your mails over
here I'm gonna sort--
What are the stacks?
Am a sort sort of,
we sorted some of her mail
sorted, some of my mail,
then sorted the rest of
her mail and then sorted--
Yeah, yeah, you don't
wanna do all sorting.
You wanna mix it up.
And then--
Just make sure that--
You wanna save a little bit
of my mail to sort last.
But the thing is is once
you've sorted your mail,
you don't wanna sort anymore mail.
That's why the male,
the males mail is sorted last.
I was like, it felt like two teenagers,
like going off into the woods in a van.
We never got to do that.
And it's like--
We never got to go parking.
I mean, not that teenagers
even cared about their mail,
but you know what I'm saying,
I mean, it felt like
teenagers sorting mail.
It was just--
I cared a lot about mail.
And then I started thinking is this,
is the purpose of this
van, this is a rental van.
Is the purpose of this rental van
so that people can take it
and go off into the wilderness
and sort their mail?
That's why I wash it so much.
Are other people's sorting
their mail right here.
That why they tell you
we've really, really,
really rinsed it down.
I started to get freaked out.
Of what?
I wasn't even done sorting in the mail
and I'm starting to get freaked out about
thinking about other people
sorting their mail in the van.
Well, have you ever been to a hotel?
And then I thought about the
hotel thing and I'm like,
but it feels different
'cause it's tighter in here.
And there's, I don't know,
it just felt a little different, okay.
And then I started
thinking, you know what,
you're overthinking this,
actually continue to overthink it.
And you'll come through
the other side, here goes.
A lot of people wanna sort the mail.
They think, you know
what, I'm going camping.
Am a bring all this mail am a sort.
Were you talking about this out loud
or just thinking about it?
No, too smart for that.
That distracts from--
But the point here,
you're not good at doing
two things at once.
So I can only imagine
that your mail sorting
was suffering significantly at this point.
Well, that's not the only thing
I had to take a break for.
I mean, it was so, I was so parched.
I had to keep my water
bottle up by my pillow
so that in the middle of the
night I could reach over.
I could grab my water bottle--
Why don't you just sleep in a camelback?
And it's a good idea, I do have one.
If you just would sleep in a camelback
and you can put it on your front,
so you don't accidentally
sleep on your stomach.
Yeah, I don't sleep on the bladder.
It's a camel front, you should get,
you should make a camel front.
Or I could just run us a
straw from my water bottle,
into my mouth and not
have to wear anything
because that's basically
why I had a tank of water.
And then--
That's gonna spill.
At one point, we were
like, we were sorting,
we're doing a good job of
sorting, like at a certain point
it's like, wow, I really know
where everything goes now.
Now that you're 42.
And then I look up and
I see my water bottle
and I grab it and I start drinking water.
And then Christy is like,
"You can't take a water.
"You're taking a water break
"in the middle of our mail sorting?"
Only Link Neal will take a water break.
I was like, I'm so parched like your nose,
like my nose is still running a little bit
because it was so trying
to moisten itself.
And like everything got so dry.
My mouth was so dry.
Oh gosh.
Yeah, but--
I started to feel better about--
You get a drink before
and after not during.
Yeah, lesson learnt but I was,
so I started to freak about
other people sorting the mail.
And then I realized, you know what?
A lot of couples they get out
here and like one of done,
one I was like, "I didn't bring my mail,"
but the other ones like
"I didn't bring my mail."
It's like, again, you both
need to bring mail to be sorted
if you really want this thing to work out.
I think most people, one
person will be thinking,
"Oh, we're going in this van,
I'm definitely bringing mail."
But both of them, maybe not.
I think most people when
they're packing everything
and they're like,
"Oh my gosh, I know I'm
gonna forget something."
At that point, even before
they left on their trip,
they say, "You know what?
"I ain't got room for mail,"
and they don't even bring it.
So then I started to feel better.
I think that we broke in that van.
So you're telling me that you
are trying to take comfort
in the fact, which I
believe is not a fact,
which is a false assumption,
that other people have
not had sex in this van.
That's just not, that's,
most couples who go camping
have sex with each other.
I never had.
You haven't been camping
with your wife before.
You just said that at the top of this.
Well, you may be right and you know what,
I need to get my own van.
Okay.
I was okay with it.
You should get your own
van for other reasons.
We didn't discuss this, it's
just happened in my mind.
I'm only discussing it with you
because I knew this is
where it would land.
I just, I think maybe
what you should realize
at this point is that
you have probably had sex
in many different places where
other people have had sex.
And most likely--
Can you say mail?
No, because I think that you're,
I think that we had
talked about this directly
at this point.
I think that the analogy
is fun but I think that
it may be making you think
incorrectly about it.
Sometimes an analogy you can get to vivid.
Yeah, It's like I have
to wear a Postal outfit.
I think that we need to
now be using literal terms.
So next time you have sexual
intercourse with your wife.
In a place that is not your home,
you need to assume that another couple
has also had sexual
intercourse in that place--
And that's fine.
And you need to be okay with that.
I was okay enough with
it to finish the job.
Not without taking a water break though.
It's totally unrelated.
And then I was like,
man I hope we're not close to other people
like when we camp other nights,
because I don't wanna be thinking,
"Are they over there sorting their mail?"
Do they think that we're
over here sorting our mail?
Does it matter?
To me that that's a more
relevant question, right?
Especially with the van doors open.
'Cause what I found is
that there is a sweet spot.
I'm not talking about sorting mail.
I'm talking about where you're,
wherever you find a place to boondock,
which is not another word for sex.
It's just means, it
sounds like one though.
But it does.
Boondocking complete,
initiating docking sequence.
Well, I mean, 'cause
if you think about it--
Yeah, you dock.
Boon is a pretty good name for it.
And docking is the perfect word.
Boondocking in the boondocks,
that's what I did, man.
Wow, boondocking.
Boondocking just means camping.
Disperse camping is the official term
on like the national forest websites.
But to me, there's a sweet spot.
You don't wanna be in an
established campground
because you're too close to people.
But as I will explain
thoroughly in my episode--
Other people don't care?
No being too remote presents itself
with a new set of problems.
There is a sweet spot
in which you're alone.
But you kinda know where
that other family is.
And we knew there was another couple,
like the first place we
went to and that like,
we could barely see them if
we look through the trees
in a certain way, like, I
mean, like over a mile away,
I had made contact with people
and then I found out another side.
You can have a conversation
with yourself in my case.
You can play your own music.
You're not thinking about,
like if you need to like walk
to the side of the campsite
and piss on a tree or something like that,
you can do all this freely.
But so I obviously I wasn't
thinking about boondocking
or sorting the mail because I was alone.
So the question for you would
be, was that on your mind,
like, could someone be
watching and does that,
would that bother you?
Well, we had already,
because we didn't wanna
shower in the shower.
Like I said, we showered out in the open
using the garden hose that
had hot and cold water,
just pick it right there
at the back of the van.
Like we did like a full on shower there.
Like shampoo, I had my
freaking loofa baby.
You brought a loofah?
I brought a loofah.
Okay, all right.
I took a naked shower.
Exfoliator.
I took a naked shower and--
It's great, it's great.
In the valley.
Bring a loofah?
Oh no, I don't bring,
I don't have a loofah
to bring, now we you--
I don't why there was
judgment in that statement.
When you go to--
I gotta get to my scary story too.
Well just quickly answer this.
Do you go, when you go to a hotel
that is like a high rise in
New York City for instance.
And one of the walls is a window.
And it faces across to another building
that has a similar setup.
And you're in it, the time
to sort the mail comes.
Do you close the windows
or do you put on a show?
I think, I don't know.
I honestly don't know.
I think I'm, I think it
depends on, I don't know.
There's a lot more variables in like
what I actually see out of the window
and how close it is.
Well, yeah, so--
If I can see other people walking around
and if they were nude, I could see them.
Like I usually, we'll wait,
usually if you turn
off most all the lights
I leave the windows open.
See, I have not been able to convince--
So it's darker.
I haven't been able to
convince my wife of this yet.
But my personal philosophy
in this situation is
if I can look to an opposing building
and I can see that there's people.
But I could not identify
them without a set of--
The position they were in.
I could identify the position.
And I could tell, okay,
there's a long haired man
and a woman or whatever you know,
but not, "Hey, there's Rhett
having sex with his wife,"
without the assistance of like
some sort of binoculars or something.
I am on team--
Open window.
Open shower curtain.
Because I've--
But when the lights are off in the room--
No, I'm team lights on open window.
No, you're not.
Lights off man.
Lights on.
Okay, all right, that's okay.
I wanna see what's happening.
But then you're encountering
resistance from your mate.
She is, she's not completely
close to the idea?
She also thinks that like,
she also thinks that like
everyone can hear and see everything.
She thinks that everyone
else on earth is Superman
in terms of how well they can see in here.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean, you gotta ease into
it, leave the curtain open,
but turn the light off, man.
Just that you need just enough light
to read what the mail
says so you can sort it.
You gotta know where it goes.
If I had to choose between
lights on or window open,
I would choose lights on because I mean--
I like a nice candle lights
or like a nice ambient light--
I don't mean like fluorescence.
I'm talking about like
the bathroom light is on--
I'm not talking about like
commercial kitchen lighting.
I'm talking about like, I wanna
be able to see everything,
but also if it's a little
bit dim, everything is,
you're both that much more
flattering to one another.
Yeah, but completely dark, no.
No, not completely, I
mean ambient lighting--
I don't want it to be fuzzy.
Ambient lighting does not allow for anyone
across the skyscraper to watch you.
But having people across the
skyscraper watch you can,
in my thinking,
I never experienced it
could be an enhancement
just for every once in a while.
Okay, all right, yeah.
All right, I wanna hear your story though.
It's not that I want to cut
that conversation short,
this is, I don't have anything to say.
It's like, okay, you know and I'm not,
am a let just thumbs up.
Well, my favorite part
about these conversations
is that after we have them
people tweet at my wife and
then I get home and she's like,
"What did you talk about?
"What were you talking about?"
We prerecorded these,
it was so long ago I don't remember that.
So it was our, this story
happens and it is not a story.
This is a true event.
A matter of fact, I
wrote down what happened.
So I wouldn't forget any of it.
And to lend credibility to it.
I didn't wanna forget anything.
And Christy had a more direct experience
with a key part of this.
So I wanted to make sure
that her story came through
correctly and not in any way, embellished.
This is how the things happened.
We'd gotten pretty good at
camping by our last night.
Like I said, we went outside of Vegas.
We were looking forward to
finding a campsite earlier
and then also leaving
later the next morning,
like to really be at a leisurely pace
and still be able to get home
before I have to return
this thing at five o'clock.
So we went up into this
Lovell Canyon Road.
It's actually, it's a road
in the middle of nowhere
on the backside of that mountain range
that overlooks Las Vegas.
You can't see anything.
I mean, it took a long
time to get up there.
Once you're gonna, once
you get on that road,
it goes for miles up into
this picturesque valley.
And then there's an occasional
gravel pull off to the side
with where people could camp.
We saw a couple of people,
but the one I was going
for was way far in there.
And we wanted cell service.
So I went, as far as we could
go, we lost cell service.
Then we came back and I saw one campsite
that was up on this berm in
the middle of this valley,
this amazing berm where we drove off of,
it was actually a paved road.
Did I say that it was like,
it was asphalt the main
road through the thing.
So it was like accessible,
more accessible than other places.
But then once you go off
of that on the dirt road,
like I was like,
I'm gonna put it in four wheel drive
because I just don't know
like going over these rocks.
It was not a smooth road at all.
It wasn't a gravel road,
it was borderline off-road
off-roading right there.
But it wasn't far that
we would go off the paved
road, we would go up this berm,
maybe 400 yards.
And there was a campsite
that had this amazing vista
on both sides.
We had cell service, but I looked,
and there was down a little saddle,
further on the off-roading and
back up like 200 yards away.
There was another, it
dipped down and went back up
and there was another berm.
And so I drove over there and
it just wasn't flat enough.
I'd learned that like,
if you don't park flat,
you don't sleep flat and that's,
it really compromises
your ability to sleep.
Did they not give you the
little blocks to balance?
No, no blocks.
I took those with me.
Those proved to be--
I underestimated, like
people are leaving reviews
about like the campsite is flat
and I'm like, I will support it.
For a tent that's really important.
But when you have a van or
you got the rooftop tent,
I just bought like 30 bucks on Amazon,
these blocks that you can stack
and all these different ways.
And I use them literally
every single night
to get under multiple
wheels to get it exactly.
It became this mission
to get the exactly flat.
Because you sleep a lot
better, if you're sliding,
especially with two people
and you're like smooshing
somebody, that's not good.
So we left that outermost berm,
we came back 200 yards
down the saddle back up
to this other berm and
then we set up shop there.
Sun was still, it was like four o'clock.
We have plenty of time
to enjoy everything.
We had, it was like 360 degree view.
You're cooking inside the van?
No, we're cooking on the,
there's a burner in there,
but then we cooked it on top of the,
that propane tank outside.
Like we had a big rectangular skillet.
We ate breakfast for dinner that night.
'Cause we had, it was our last night
and we had eggs and bacon,
Christy made the bacon,
she fried the bacon and it's spelled Link,
she's knows the way to my heart.
Wow.
Yeah, pretty great, huh?
We're having a great time,
we're listening to Sea Change by Beck.
That's a big pan or small bacon.
Yeah, the pain was this big.
And then the sun's going down and some,
I think there is some smoke residue
or it might've just been
so hot, the ambient heat,
it created this amazing
effect on the sunset.
And I was like, literally
the most amazing sunset
we've ever seen.
Like it was wonderful, we were
having the time of our lives.
And then we ate dinner
as it was getting dark.
And then because she made the dinner,
I was on dish duty inside of the camper.
And she was sitting outside,
I think reading something
by or like on her phone.
'Cause she had service.
And by this point it's dark.
It's like nine o'clock, okay.
And I'm like finishing
up washing the dishes,
and earlier in the day before it got dark,
we heard a car coming up
the road and it was again,
it was still light.
And so I stepped out of the
camper to just let them know
that like, "Hey, there's two people here."
And I'm gonna suss out
these people going by.
People coming up the dirt road.
Yeah, coming up the dirt road.
And they had to go right beside our van
to then go down that little thing
to go to that next site
that we decided not to take.
Well really early on one guy
along with a rooftop tent
went there, he parked and we're like,
"Oh man, is he gonna say,"
we can't shower there now.
'Cause he would see us.
He stayed there for five
minutes then he left, later on--
Yeah, you can't be crowding people, man.
It's a freaking desert,
there's all kinds of--
Later on it's almost sunset this other man
and it looked like his
teenage daughter came through
and then they went up and
checked out the same spot.
And then we're like watching
and we could see them.
We could see and they got out of their car
and they set up a tent and they stayed.
So we were a little bit bound,
but like we were facing the
other direction and they were on
the other side of the van, like I said,
200 yards away on another berm.
So we still felt like we
had pretty good privacy.
And then sun went down, we ate our dinner,
it's nine o'clock at night.
I'm inside washing the dishes,
she's outside on her phone.
And all of a sudden I hear
gravel and I see like headlights
hit the side of our van
and a car is creeping up the dirt road
coming right up to us.
And like I'm in there washing.
And the car comes past my field of view
and stops where I can't see the car.
I can't see who's driving
the car or anything.
I can just see the tail of the car
from where I was washing the dishes,
but I could see Christy
and she could see this car of course.
'Cause she was out there in the open.
And then the car stops--
Right next to you.
Right next to the back of our van.
And I hear a guy say to Christy,
"Are you selling any hot dogs?"
And Christy said, and I freeze.
And I'm like,
"What the hell is this guy
asking about hot dogs?"
And I'm like, I literally freeze
and I'm like just listening.
'Cause it was hard for me to hear.
But my instinct was just to listen.
So let me just, here's the exchange.
"Are you selling any hot dogs?"
And then I hear Christie say,
"Nope, we actually don't have any."
And then the guy says,
"I'm going around getting people to vote,
"vote on my pictures, to see
which ones they like best."
And I'm still listening
and then Christy goes,
"No, thank you, we're not interested."
And she was like really
has a friendly voice.
And then the guy said,
"I just need you to vote on the photos.
"See I have them right here."
And I can't see him and then Christie--
Hold on and you're still--
Christy stood up.
You're still in the kitchen?
I'm still in the kitchen frozen.
Like washing, like you gotta
be out there at this point.
In retrospect I was
trying to figure out why,
it was a frightened?
Was I frozen with fear?
Was I being strategic?
Being strategic.
I think all of these were having,
because my initial thing was--
The strategic hesitation.
It's not basketball.
I was trying to assess the
situation, I was freaked out.
I was like, what the heck is going on?
Like when the people came around earlier,
I had come out and show my face.
But my instincts told me to sit back here.
Christy is gonna,
I need to do whatever it takes
to deescalate the situation.
This guy seems strange.
A little.
Very strange.
And I think I was just like,
Christy is going to politely
get this guy to drive off.
If I go out there and like say something,
I might say the wrong,
I had this instinct that I
was gonna say the wrong thing.
And I will say--
You might escalate.
I had had a couple, okay?
Okay.
So I wasn't, I was just
trying to know my limitations
and I was like, I might go out there
and I might be aggressive
or I might try to scare
the guy, you know how I do.
And that is your MO when you
enter into weird situations
like that and you come in
pretty aggressive and pretty strong.
And if I had it, yeah, I escalate things.
And if I've had a few, I speak louder.
And so I think I didn't have enough that
I didn't know that about myself.
So my instinct told me
Christy's gonna deescalate this.
I'm gonna stay back here
and then I can assess
what I need to do when the time is right.
So, I mean, he's like,
"I'm going around getting
people to vote on my pictures,
"to see which ones they like best."
And then Christy's like,
"No, thank you, we're not interested."
And then he said,
"I just need you to vote on the photos.
"See I have them right here."
And then Christie told me that he holds up
like four by six photos.
It wasn't on a phone,
it was literal photo.
He had printed out photos and he was,
of course he's in the driver's seat.
He's leaning over the passenger seat,
trying to lure Christy close to the car
to show her the pictures.
How old is this guy?
What does he look?
Christy said, it's very dark.
Again, there's no moon.
We had turned most of our lights off--
You're way out there.
We're way out there, yes.
And Christy was like,
"Ah, well, no, we're
just wrapping up dinner."
And then she said she couldn't
see his face that well,
but it was just,
it was one guy in the
car and it was like a,
it was a hatchback car.
It could have been like a
Subaru Outback type thing
that could have gone on
this off-roading part.
But if you're in a car and
you go slow enough, you can,
you could navigate it.
And so it was just a hatchback
that's all we could tell.
He was, he's leaning
from the driver's side.
So she can't really see his face,
but it's just some white dude.
I mean, she couldn't
describe him more than that.
And then he's like, she's like,
"We were just wrapping up dinner."
And so she said, he was like, "Okay."
And he throws his hand up
in the air, like whatever.
And then he slowly keeps going past us--
To the other people--
Down into that thing in an
up to those next people.
And at that moment that
he drove away, Christy,
I'm still in the kitchen,
Christy comes in there
and she's visibly freaking
out and I'm also freaking out.
And like, our eyes are so wide
and it was like, we were
like, what just happened
is what we seem to be saying to each other
without actually saying words.
And I was just like, she was like,
"Was this guy trying to,
"this guy was trying
to lure me to the car."
I was like, "Yeah, I didn't
know if I should go out there
"or if I should wait,
"but it felt like you were handling it."
And I was like, "I just didn't,
"I just wanted him to go away.
"And it seemed like you were
doing a good job of that."
And she was like, and I was thinking,
"We gotta get outta here."
He's going to these,
this guy's unpredictable.
He maybe unstable--
Did you have a knife or anything?
I wasn't thinking of that at
the time I have one of those
like five and one tools
that has a knife in it.
I have a giant knife.
Like a hunting knife
that's like 12 inches long.
And I kept it in my tent every night
just in case trouble came.
Yeah, yeah, well, let me tell you,
I gotta rethink some things.
To think things through on another level,
because at this point
I'm thinking in my mind,
I know Christy wants to
get the hell out of dodge.
And I'm also thinking--
He's got to come back
by you, right, because--
We knew that he had to come back by us
once he was done--
Once the dad and the daughter
were done judging the photos.
Yes or once he's done like
killing and eating them,
there is a dead end, he
has to come back by us.
So we were freaking out that
we knew he was coming back by.
Also you still got a cell service.
Did it hit you that maybe
you should call the police at that point.
Christy said, let's call the cops.
And I'm like, "Let's
not call the cops yet,
"let's not panic."
And I just didn't feel like, I don't know.
I just didn't wanna call the cops.
We can put a, let's put a pin in that.
Okay, I'm not saying that you definitively
should have called the cops at that point.
Christy was talking about
let's call the cops,
there was a debate.
There's odd, there's something
not right about this guy.
There's several things
So Christy was like,
"You need to pack everything up
"so that when he comes back
through, we can be ready.
"We can be in the van,
locked up and we can,
"if we need to leave, we can just leave."
So I was like, listen Christy,
and we turned off all
the lights in the van
so that we could see
through our little window.
We watched him drive down
there to those other people,
with all of our lights on.
We couldn't see him that
well so we're like--
How easy is it to pack up?
We doused everything and then I was like,
"Christy, you look out at this window
"and you keep your eyes glued to this guy.
"If he starts coming back, you let me know
"while you don't take your
eyes off of his car lights.
"I'm gonna get everything cleaned up."
And then I went out there and I got,
the propane tank had just,
propane burner had just cooled down enough
to put it in the car, the
propane tank, our chairs,
the cooler, I'm scrambling
putting everything away
in the pitch dark without any lights on.
And then I put everything
back in and I come back in
and she's like, "He still there."
Yeah, I mean, he's got a lot
of photos to go through."
He's still there, I
don't, you know, did he,
did he kill both of them?
I don't know, what's he doing?
Is he putting on their skin as a suit?
I don't know what's happening,
but I'm thinking if we,
and I asked Christie, this is like,
"If we're watching a
movie of us right now,
"what would we be saying
to our characters?
"Get the hell out of here."
Yeah, but in the movie that
you would definitely have judged
the photos because of what,
I mean, that's what would
be more fun for a plot.
Well, really, let me see your photos.
Christy would have, Christy
did stand up I think,
but she did not walk towards
the man with the photos.
We knew he was coming back and we're like,
I don't wanna be the people in the movie
that I'm gonna be angry at.
We need to be ready to leave.
So like we locked up the
van, we locked up everything.
And then all of a sudden
that the car starts moving
and it starts creeping back.
And because of the terrain,
it had to go so slow.
And it went down in
that berm and it came up
and we're looking out the
back two windows of the van
where he would drive right past us.
And he drives and he gets,
comes right up to the van
and then keeps going slowly.
And he goes down below the van
and he gets back to the paved road
and we could still see him.
And he stops there at the
paved road and he doesn't,
he has to turn right or left.
He doesn't turn anywhere.
He sits there for a
long time and I'm like--
Like how long?
It felt like 10 minutes.
Like he was like, I don't
know, what is he blocking
our only exit.
Like we're cowering in this van locked up.
And then he turns left
and we like watch him
go down into the canyon.
And then we watched him
go up on another berm
where a long ways away,
we saw that there was
another camper and it's like,
Christy is like, "We
need to get out of here."
And it was like, she was
like, you've, you can't drive.
It's like, "You don't wanna get a DUI."
She didn't want her first experience
driving the sprinter
van to being off road,
so then it's like, you just need to like,
you just need to just take some time.
How long do you think it's gonna take you
for you feel like you can drive
and I'm like, "Ah, an hour."
And then like,
we're just sitting there
in the dark freaked out.
You can see, you can still see,
you can kinda see where he went.
I see that he went to another site
and then like over 20 minutes
of processing this I'm like,
you know what?
It's a paved road down
the middle of this thing.
This guy's a little off, but I bet you,
he comes up in here
and tries to sell his pictures to campers.
And I'm like, Christy, he said,
"I'm not trying to sell you anything
"I just want you to vote on my pictures."
But then when you said,
"I like this one best
I'm voting for this."
He would say, "I'll sell
it to you for 5 dollars."
'Cause it was like
pictures of like nature.
Wasn't pictures of him like posing?
Yeah, yeah.
Which would have been especially weird.
It wasn't like you and like
a New York City exhibition.
Right, yeah.
In your bedroom.
So I'm like, this guy
is just a strange guy
who likes to sell his
pictures to like campers
in the pitch black of night.
Yeah, not a great strategy.
And then she's like,
"Well, I would feel better if we went
"and talked to that other couple."
And I'm like, "If we drive up there,
"there's no place to turn around
"because of where they parked,
"I can't turn this van around."
That's probably why it
took him so long up there
because he couldn't turn his car around
and I'm trying, I'm like, I'm
getting my wits about me now.
I'm not freaking out as much.
And I'm trying to deescalate
how scared Christy is.
And I'm like, and then we start,
so we start walking down into the ravine,
up to where this other camping group is,
the dad and the daughter.
And we get halfway there
and like you can hear
someone's on a laptop
or like watching a show or something.
But then it's like, it's so dark out there
and I'd just had a headlamp.
And I was like,
"We're gonna freak them
out by going up there."
And we just, we got too
scared to walk up to them.
And we turned around and
walked back and we were like,
I'm scared, we were like, laughing.
Christy had not had anything by the way.
She was just like, she's just predisposed
to be freaked out by this stuff.
And she doesn't like to drive off road,
which stuck us in this middle ground
where like huddled back at the van,
afraid this guy's gonna come back.
And I'm like, listen, this is fine.
She was, "I really would feel better
"if we talked to this other people."
So we walked out there again.
Did you make it this time?
We get halfway and we get
scared again and we come back.
Hold on, you're scared--
I don't know, we were just so freaked out
that we didn't wanna go--
Scared of freaking them
out, 'cause I get that.
We were scared of freaking them out.
What if after all this, like
that guy has a knife or a gun.
And like, he's trying
to protect his daughter.
And we're the ones
who get caught in the
crossfire or something.
'Cause we freaked him out
and we were gonna yell at
him and then it's like,
you don't want to yell.
"Hey, we want to talk
to you about that guy
"that tried to get you
to judge the photos."
We go back and I'm like,
"Listen, everything is fine.
"We're locked up in this van--"
And you sleep inside the van.
We sleep inside the van, it's locked up.
So we got calm and we're like,
we're just gonna chill out here.
And then we're like, we're here, I mean,
we're just bedding down for the night.
I got some mail.
This is not a great time.
We could sort some out.
You know what, surprisingly enough,
there was enough mail
on both sides to sort
that it actually, sometimes
when you clean up,
it gives you a sense of control.
I think sometimes sorting the mail
gives you a sense of release.
Well, it's like a gorilla,
when a gorilla is trying to--
Express dominates.
Dominate another gorilla,
gets an erection and shows it.
And it's actually way smaller
than you would expect for a gorilla.
'Cause you would know that like
anyone who's really scared
can't get an erection.
If there are even not even just a gorilla,
like I'm talking about me now.
So being able to get
an erection and use it,
is actually the ultimate show
that you're completely relaxed.
We were completely
relaxed, we were over it.
In fact, come on back, let
me buy some of your photos.
And then, so then I was
feeling pretty good.
And we were like getting everything,
like I probably got a drink of water
and I got up and it's
like, all of a sudden,
the sliding door on
the van begins to open.
Now it's a big electric sliding door.
So it's like, you pull the handle
and then it like goes
out and then it slowly,
and it was dirt, so it took
a while for it to open.
I did not, the keys were up in the front
where I'd locked the van.
Christy didn't have them,
we didn't touch any buttons
that would have opened the door.
100%, we did not do
anything to open the door.
But here we are, the door is opening
and I'm standing there looking
out the door as it's opening,
waiting to see this guy standing there,
it scared the shit out of me.
And also Christy,
like she literally had
to go to the bathroom.
Once we found out there
was no one standing there.
I don't know why the door opened.
But there was,
my theory is there's some
sort of voice command
that connects to like
the entertainment system.
You didn't know about the voice command?
And I don't think that the voice,
sometimes it would come on.
Kind of like, hey, when you
say, "Hey Siri," so it's,
but I don't have any proof that
that would actually work with the van.
Maybe we, it wasn't locked all the way
and when I showed--
Had you said like open?
No, I was, I did not
want the door to open.
I'm so open right now.
There was nothing on the
other side of that van door
except blackness, it was so dark.
It scared me, but--
You expected the guy to be standing there
with two photos.
Yeah, he wasn't there.
Which one do you like, just tell me.
And then Christy,
at this point Christy wasn't freaking out.
And I was like, I think
it was the voice thing
because something lit up on
the entertainment consol,
I was lying.
And so she was fine and she
wasn't freaking out about it.
So then I closed the door
back and then I made sure
everything was locked.
And then we laid back down in the bed
and Christy kept looking at those,
she was looking through the window,
but like I rolled over and went to sleep.
I don't know how long I was asleep.
Christy said I was snoring,
but she was wide awake and
looking out the window.
And then what I woke up to
was Christy grabbing my thigh.
This story is still going.
Yes.
She grabbed my thigh
and it was probably 10:30 at this point.
I woke up out of asleep
and like eyes wide open,
headlights shining through
the back of the van
in my face.
Did you immediately recognize
the same headlights?
And I couldn't see
cause it was headlights.
And then the car is creeping towards us
and coming right up to our van.
And then it slowly goes
by and it's the same car.
It's a hatchback.
I will say for a fact,
it's a hatchback car
and it keeps going by
and we are freaking out.
I mean every time that
we've been freaking out
this whole time with all the lights off
Christy and I've been
whispering to each other,
we haven't been talking to loud voice.
We've been like, whispering,
like what do we do?
And it was like, "Oh shit, I think that's,
"I don't think it's the same car."
I'm like telling Christy I'm
like, that's a different car.
It's boxier.
Yeah boxier.
I'm lying.
I'm thinking this is
the same freaking car,
this is picture man.
And he goes by us, he
knows this, a dead end.
He goes down into that saddle
and then I can barely see
his car stop, brake lights.
He doesn't go up to the, to those people.
His car stops down in the
bottom 100 yards from us
and 100 yards from them.
And then all of a sudden
the lights in the car go off
and I'm waiting for the interior,
I'm waiting for the
interior light to come on,
when the car door opens.
They don't.
It doesn't.
He's bending down.
It's totally black.
And then we just sat
there for a long time,
just watching to see if
there's any signs of this guy
getting out of his car 'cause
I'm like, and then I'm like,
I sat up and I'm like, just keep watching.
I'm getting in the driver's seat.
And we're getting the hell out of here.
And I got in the driver's seat
and I backed that puppy up.
And we drove out of there
because the guy was just there,
at any moment, he could
have got out of the car,
walked up there and
made a skin into a suit,
my skin into a suit.
You have no choice, now--
And so we drove down
to the end of the road
where we pulled off the main road
and we were still in a place where,
we just parked over there.
We saw someone else camping,
we camped kinda near them.
We just parked and we felt much better
and we slept that night and
got up the next morning.
But I wanted to go ride back up there
and see if anybody was still up there.
But we didn't do it.
'Cause what about the
dad and the daughter?
Well they were alive
the first time he left
and then the second time
he didn't go back up there.
But like he might've blocked them in.
That's the scaredest I've ever been.
And it was like multiple
freaking parts to it.
And maybe we should
call the ranger even now
and tell him, "Hey, heads up.
"There's some dude with pictures."
If there's a, I don't have
much of a description, but--
Maybe this is what's
happening with this guy.
Maybe years ago he made a
deal with the devil of sorts.
And now every night he has to piss--
My armpits are starting to sweat again.
He has to get someone
to buy one of his photos
or else he turns into a pumpkin.
And I think what happened is,
is that either he succeeded or he didn't,
and he goes back to that spot.
And if you had to stuck
around until midnight,
you would have seen him
turn into a pumpkin.
What do you think really happened though?
I think the guy was a little off,
but he was just trying to make scratch,
selling these pictures of nature.
And I'm dying to know what
he said to those people,
but I was too scared to walk
up there and I'm mad at myself.
And what did they,
did they see him coming up?
'Cause I mean, if they were freaked out,
then they see this guy come down
and stop at the bottom of the ravine.
You think that they
knew that he was there?
Yeah, they definitely would have seen him.
And he's on the road.
'Cause they can't get around him.
Yeah, I did a bad thing, did I?
We abandoned these people.
Those people got boxed in
by this guy, who knows what,
and this just happened two nights ago,
you might need to look at the news.
And it might be like father and daughter
murdered by crazed photo
man outside of Las Vegas.
And if happened--
While other couple of sorts
of mail in the close vicinity.
And now you've told your
whole story, which includes,
well, we saw him, we
got a little bit scared.
We had sex and then we left.
No, he came back.
You have no alibi at this point.
You don't really need an
alibi 'cause you, but I mean,
you definitely are an accomplice to this.
I don't like calling the cops
because I didn't wanna like trouble them.
They got things to worry
about other than that,
it's like, and I couldn't
describe my exact location.
I was like, well, we're up to canyon road
and we still have cell service.
So we're not too far in, but we're not,
we're really far in.
It's one of those situations
and I'm not saying I would have,
I don't think I would have
acted any differently,
but it's one of those things that
you wish you could go back.
And the moment that he shows up,
you could just say something like,
"Hey bro, let's talk about this.
"You understand what you're doing
"is very weird and threatening.
"It's dark, we're out here
in the middle of nowhere.
"You're asking these weird
questions about selling hotdogs
"and then asking us to judge your photos.
"This makes my wife and I feel unsafe."
"Oh, well, in that case,
let me shoot you in the face
"and turn your skin into a suit."
I don't think that would happen,
I think the reaction would be,
"Oh, you're right, I'm not crazy anymore."
No, no, they'd be crazy
but you would at least say,
"So dude, go away or I'm
gonna call the police."
I'm not saying I would
have done that going in,
but if this ever happens
to meet to me now,
that's what I'm gonna do.
I feel more prepared now I
would have gone out there
and I would've said something.
Here's the thing that I've learned
whenever you're out there camping.
And there are people going by,
like when that dad and daughter went by,
I probably would have waved
them down and had a conversation
because that way it's
like, I have an assessment
of who these people are on this next berm.
And then I would have
confidence if I needed to,
if I needed help or if I
needed to check on them,
I know I've confidence
that I know who they are.
That was part of why I was
scared to go over there.
'Cause I didn't, I don't know
that it was a dad daughter.
It was like, it was a
weird age difference.
Yeah, but--
So, you know.
Maybe that's what they do.
I don't know, it's, maybe this,
maybe the photo person was with them
and they spent a lot of time
there and they were like--
They're a team, huh?
It's not a very effective plan.
They need to work on their strategy.
I don't know what the end game is.
I can get better at being ready
for this type of thing.
And then again, not escalating it.
The main thing is like, after I was like,
as it was happening, I was
like, "Okay, if we don't die,
"this is the end of me and Christy
"ever going camping again."
And I was mad.
Yeah, that guy ruined it.
But you know what?
She actually took it in
stride with our entire trip
and all the other things
that happened and--
And at least it happened the last night.
We had a positive experience--
If it happened in the first night--
So many positive experiences that it,
that this scary thing did not outweigh it.
So just to kind of shut this
down in a positive place,
I'm not saying I'm definitely
gonna buy one of these
off-road sprinter van outfits
because I've got three kids
and there's a lot of problems
associated with that.
Space was of a premium let me tell you.
How many people could you
comfortably take on a trip.
We could have brought Lando
and there's one place that could lay out
where he could sleep in a separate bed.
But also--
But you could do a rooftop tent
or just set up a tent.
Take a tent.
Yeah.
'Cause my rooftop tent is
rated for three people,
but they would be very small people.
So I think I could either
have Jesse or one of the kids.
And so I was like, "Well,
I'll just take an extra tent,
"put it on the ground."
If that guy would have
been on the other side
of that sliding door,
like I have no explanation
for why it opened,
but that, I've never been
so scared as that moment.
That's why you gotta have a knife, man.
That's why I was yeah, like,
and I needed to have
that knife in my hand.
I had bear spray, had a
bull horn and a giant knife.
I, yeah, I've never been more scared
than at that moment because like,
I just remember the
feeling of peering over
into the darkness as the door.
It could not have opened slower.
And I just knew that he was
just gonna be standing there.
Yeah, we're not prepared
for that kind of thing.
Like, because we live in such
a controlled civilized society
at this point, you go
back in several hundred,
several thousand years.
First of all, you wouldn't be in a van
because they didn't exist.
But if you hadn't been in
a van and the door opened,
you would be immediately
like in an aggressive,
like you would have been so ready.
Like you would have
been punched in the air.
You know what I'm saying?
This is what I looked like.
You're right, yeah.
You were totally, you were petrified, man.
I was like sticking my
neck out to be chopped.
We've lost the ability
to just take life by the horns, man.
We've been cuddled.
We should all be, we should have knives.
I'm gonna have so many knives.
We should have--
Am a have throwing knives.
We should have claw, like
gloves that have claws on them.
So you're saying that Link Neal
should go out into the woods
'cause playing as Wolverine.
Is that a good idea?
I mean you might hurt yourself and others,
but you'll also protect
yourself and others.
The first night, I couldn't
figure out the freaking van.
This is another point of reference like,
we were bend down for
the night and I'm like,
I can't get the cab lights to turn off
in the front of the cab, I
can't get them to turn off.
I was pushing buttons everywhere.
I accidentally pressed the
SOS button on the Mercedes.
Oh, that's a problem.
And all of a sudden I heard it--
Hello can I help you.
I heard a number.
I heard it, it's ringing
and I'm pushing buttons
and I can't get it to stop.
Well, they'll ask you if
it's a true emergency.
And then all of a sudden they were like,
"Hello is an emergency"
And I was like,--
"No, I'm one of the 98% of the people
"who accidentally press this button
"that you talked to all night long."
Now what I said was, he said,
"Hello, is this an emergency?"
And I said,
"No, but can you help me
with a technical issue?"
No you didn't.
And she said, "No, this is
for emergency uses only."
I'm like, "Okay, well, I
didn't even mean to call you.
"I just hit the number by,
"hit the button by accident."
And she hung up.
And then I ended up
pressing the SOS button
three more times by accident,
trying to figure out how
to turn the lights off.
But she never answered
again, I got blocked.
Cried wolf.
And then I got in bed and I'm like,
"I'm sorry, Christy, the
cab lights are gonna be on.
"It's going to be ambient."
And then she's like, "I'm scared."
This is the first night, she said,
"I'm scared of sleeping
with the doors open
"on the back of the van."
So I was like, I went
around, walked outside,
close the doors, 'cause that's
how you have to close them.
And then as I was
walking back, I was like,
that's why the damn lights were on.
So then I closed all the doors
and I hit the lock button
and the van locked and
all the lights went off.
And that's how I know that,
I don't know how that door
opened for the creepy guy
to not be there because
I had figured it out.
But everything was so
hard to figure it out.
But can you have the doors
open and the lights off.
Surely you can.
You can't hit the lock button.
If you hit the lock
button, the lights stay on
to let you know that you
didn't actually lock your van
because there's doors gaped open.
Got it, yeah.
So you have to learn to
speak the van's language.
Maybe I'll get one, maybe not,
but I definitely have an appreciation
for going out into nature and just like,
and bringing my mail.
I don't know if I ever wanna
bring my kids, honestly,
maybe just one kid at
a time type of thing.
If I have this van, I
can do smaller trips too.
It doesn't have to always be.
I'm trying to talk to you
into talking me into this.
You can come.
Me and you can take the van.
Yeah, but we gotta share a bed, right?
I will have a different what?
Put a rooftop tent on it.
You can put a rooftop tent on the van.
That'll be way up there.
You're used to it.
That's true.
You definitely should do it man.
That may have been the scaredest
I've ever been, period.
I mean, I haven't had
anything that legitimately I,
as I'll share in my episode--
I'm just trying to get
people to vote on my picture.
Lots of, first off I
thought you're gonna say,
I'm just trying to get people to vote.
I was like, "Oh, great."
That's what I thought,
I was like, this guy in
the middle of nowhere.
You're trying to get out the vote.
Yeah, man, whatever it takes.
That's what I thought.
Every vote counts.
I was so--
Nevada is a swing state.
Everything he said was so strange
that I was just frozen in fear
and lack of assertiveness.
But Christy handle herself like a master.
Now here's the thing.
My wife would be really mad at me.
If I had behaved like you
did at the beginning--
I was surprised Christy wasn't mad at me
'cause I think I deserve it.
There's this one time
and she never lets me live this down.
we were in Chapel Hill,
been married for like a year
and there was a homeless man
who was aggressive and kinda
like kinda coming at us and--
You pushed her.
No, I didn't push her
Take her, not me.
What if that's what I could do?
Take the small one.
I had seen this guy before and he was,
he would get in people's faces and--
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Most of the time, the
vast majority of the time,
if a person in this situation
gets aggressive it's all talk,
it's all bark, no bite, right?
So we're just walking along
and she is on the side that he's,
and he kinda comes at us and
I just sort of looked at him
and just kept walking unthreatened,
but I didn't get in front of her.
And I didn't bow up to the guy because
in my mind this guy's
just a little bit nuts.
He does this kind of aggressive thing.
He comes up to you and
then you just walk by.
But for our entire marriage,
she has held that against me,
that in her in her mind,
I pushed her to this guy.
And so now I have this conscious
thing where it's just like,
if we're in a situation
where someone is threatening,
I've gotta like insert myself.
But I haven't even yet
had the opportunity.
Because remember that age old,
the story of Christy was
pregnant and the guy--
Yeah, right.
The guy with the football--
You tend to come in a little bit hard.
What are you doing.
I got to swing the pendulum back.
All right let me shut this down.
And let me make a quick wreck.
It's my turn to make a wreck.
On a, let's see, not the
last, but the AMA before that,
the Mythical Society
AMA we do every month.
Somebody asked what I was listening to
and I told them what we were listening to,
am a make it a recommendation.
Zephaniah Ohora, this guy
channels Merle Haggard
and he's like, I mean, I'm
not telling you anything
you don't know 'cause
we discovered this guy.
He channels Merle Haggard on these like,
these vintage country music tracks,
he's out of Brooklyn.
It's pretty phenomenal.
My favorite song "We
Planned to Have It All,"
is like a early 80s Merle.
He usually goes like some
of the earlier Merle,
but we really liked that early 80s Merle.
Not that like early 70s Merle.
We love it, but that's our sweet spot.
"We Planned to Have It All is the song"
that I am recommending by Zephaniah Ohora
off the album, "Listening to the Music."
Oh man, I gotta get out of the sweatshirt.
I just been sweating too much.
And if you're out there
and you're listening to this podcast
and you have a tendency
to just approach people
just outside of Vegas,
in the dark to get them to buy
or just vote on your photos,
just understand or buy people's hotdogs.
That's your opening line.
This is not a good strategy
for selling your photos.
You've frightened,
you frightened at least
one family that night
and you're on the verge of being reported.
It hasn't happened yet though.
It hasn't happened yet.
Just know probably next time, some,
the next person you approach in this way
will probably call the authorities.
Or stab you.
And if that person is me,
both those things I guess will happen
'cause now I'm ready for it.
Hashtag Ear Biscuits.
We'll hear about Rhett's amazing
solitary experience next time.
No, I didn't run into
that guy, spoiler alert.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.